my name is otis and um first of all i'd
like to thank um judy for inviting me i
feel really um humbled to be in front of
it i almost feel unworthy to be in the
on the panel of these people but thank
you for giving me this opportunity so
today i want to talk about um popular
culture and education in mathematics so
um a little bit about me
so in high school i like playing this
chinese instrument called the uhu and um
i was always um i did it for music in
the hsc and i was always really
passionate about my music
and i thought oh how can i integrate um
this part of my life with this part of
my life which is mathematics and um
first of all in terms of like talking
giving like a bit of a springboard of
what i want to talk about i'm going to
play a little bit of an excerpt of
something that i'm really also really
passionate about and if you recognize
this
song
i think you're not studying enough for
the undergrads
um so it goes like this
so for those people that don't know that
that's um a theme song from game of
thrones yeah so um yeah so i kind of
wanted to
i used a lot of my time watching game of
thrones the part of that yeah
um
so um this is the kind of lesson i
wanted to share with everyone i actually
kept it an original form when i wrote it
in second year and i'm currently my
fourth year now and so you can see that
uses um it uses the old syllabus so i'm
trying to teach my cost price profit
things like that and i wanted to try and
use a creative way to integrate music
into teaching this subject so um i'm
going to play a little bit an exit of
something else i'm really passionate
about which is um
the voice
me
okay so quickly jumping back to my
presentation so as you all know um
the um the voice the second season is
coming out soon or like the second third
season anyways
that's something i really like i enjoy
watching and i'm sure a lot of people in
the audience can relate to it and also
game of thrones and things like that so
um i'm trying to think of a way so i'm
in this point where okay i love music
love my popular media how do i integrate
that into maths and um
so
i kind of thought about using um like a
bit of a springboard let's talk about um
delta stress okay made by lisa
right and i'm thinking oh okay delta
stress before she wore it was about
fifty dollars now after the show she's
worn it just because she's on stage it's
become 250 dollars how does this relate
to how much profit has she made things
like this um and also one or two
it's the most out there it's kind of not
parallel but if you think of like
bouncing off the creativity part yeah i
feel like um yeah this is what really
inspired me so i kind of use um like the
blooms taxonomy thing that we've been
talking about in um that equitable
education thing um when we talk about
okay first of all very simple questions
like what is the cost of the outfit how
much is it selling for what is the
profit but then we can delve a little
bit deeper and think about um
things that i'm passionate about like
that's such as like what why why does
marketing exist in the world and how
does that influence people's thinking
and really relate that back down to
their lives
um
so there's a lot of um so i just like
well i remember
when i was driving to prak um in the
morning it took me an hour to go to um
from where i live and i always used to
listen to carl and jackie oh which is um
the most you know not to stay there
the quality of their work or anything
but it allowed me to keep up up to date
with what's going on really in society
in a sense and
if you know what i mean
so
why i'm doing this and
i'm sure that everyone has their phone
right now and then on their facebook you
know they're scrolling up and down so
next time um i suggest you you in the
next 20 minutes or so you probably do
this when you scroll up and down and go
update think about a way that you can
integrate what you see on your newsfeed
into your teaching so i find that it
develops a bit of a commonality between
your students
and it brings
brings the lives of students and
teachers into a classroom that harnesses
greater engagement i that's i felt that
during prac when i could uh really
relate to my students because i was
talking about voice so i was talking
about so thinking of dance and um
yeah and it provides this sense of
belonging in a society and i hope that
even like subject-like mathematics
i will be able to address issues that
directly affect the lives of my students
and be a part of the development of
students that think critically about
their world that they live in so not
just
think about how mathematics really
relates to their lives and on a final
note uh this is something i created for
my um
presentation
so um how do we do this one
can anyone have our clues not in my
curriculum class
um what about so this is how i did it
so
what about um intersection between two
lines um like a radio signal from one uh
one country and another radio signal
from one country is the exact location
and each each group is given one small
piece of information and then to trade
that piece of information and pass it on
you know and then they can find out how
they do that i don't know just bouncing
off things like this and this is
something i found online
thank you for having me